[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we had been
discussing the
hemost displacement potential stemming
basically from the hemols
representation theorem in this lecture
we are going to discuss
another displacement potential and we
would like to see the connections with
the
hemo's displacement potential at least
some
some relationships as regards the
solution
so
[Music]
more commonly this is referred to as the
lami's
strain potential instead of the lamb is
displacement potential
uh we'll just refer to his as the
lamy's potential okay
so and please note that this lamy
it is the same scientist after whom the
lamy's parameters
are named in the linear elastic
isotropic material behavior so the
lambda
and the g which we keep on using to
connect the stresses with the strains
for a linear elastic isotropic material
behavior those two material parameters
those those lamina's parameters it is
the same lamy here
all right so what lami said
was that the displacement vector
can be represented in this particular
form
so what i'll do is because i have
already utilized
this particular symbol phi in the
hemel's
uh displacement potential i will
slightly change it
and represent it by this file okay so if
you're typesetting it
uh some of you already know this this is
actually the five
uh or the fee as some people call it and
the other one
which i had just written this one that
is uh referred to at least in latex
as verify okay so that's just a side
talk
uh so what do we do with this thing so
first of all you note
that uh if you just discount this
coefficient of 1 by 2
g then this
form of the displacement vector being
represented as the gradient
of a scalar potential it is very much
reminiscent
of what we did back in our kinematics
chapter
to represent the irrotational dis uh of
an illusional
displacement field and you can check
that yourself if you just take the curl
of the displacement vector that is equal
to
uh this 1 by 2 g factor is there of
course
but it is just the curl of
this thing and this is identically zero
okay so this is identically true
that means that this lam is a potential
okay so the implication is that the
lam is potential
is strictly limited
to a rotational phase
this is very very important to note okay
so what is the implication of of
considering such a displacement
potential
so just like as as we had done for the
hemols displacement potential we utilize
the displacement vector
uh in the in the navier lamies equation
uh so so just to recall the navier
lamins equation is basically
uh we start with this
form of the stress equilibrium equation
and from this by substituting the
expressions for the stresses
in terms of the strains and then
subsequently those strains in terms of
the displacement we end up with
this particular form
this particular form of the equation
which we had done which we had mentioned
in our
previous lecture on the hemos
displacement potential also
uh so this is the the navier lamins
equation
okay so again you come across the name
lamin so his name occurs again and again
uh all throughout our studies of
elasticity
all right so we had also seen in the
previous lecture that if we use
a particular vector identity then we end
up with
another form of this equation which is
lambda plus twice g grad
div of u minus
g third
of the curl of u
okay so these two statements are
perfectly equivalent
now what we intend to do here is to
specialize
to the to the to our current situation
okay so whatever we have written these
three steps these are
uh these are applicable for any general
systems
as long as we are considering linear
elastic isotropic material behavior
when we consider this particular form of
the displacement potential
then you immediately note that
this curl of u that is 0
for our current situation this is equal
to 0
and this divergence of u okay
so you can immediately write here the
divergence of
u that is simply 1 by twice g
the laplacian of phi as easy as that
so what we end up with is this
lambda plus twice g
the grad of the laplacian
of pi the grad of the laplacian of phi
this is zero plus rho b vector
is equal to zero all right
now again we are ending up with a with a
with a kind of
situation uh where
the body forces are kind of bothering us
because if you look back
at what we had discussed during the
hemorrhoids displacement potential
there also we had ended up with an
equation involving
uh certain uh
forms uh involving the laplacians and
and what not of the of the phi and the
omega
but it was due to the presence of the
body forces that we couldn't say much
it was only when we said the body forces
to be equal to zero
that we were able to proceed and find
out uh
two more convenient forms of the
equation
okay so what i'm referring to here if we
just look back
a little bit so this is what i'm saying
this is exactly what i'm saying here so
we had considered the row b vector to be
equal to zero so this is referring back
to the hemus displacement potential
framework and subsequently as a
consequence of
setting the row b vector equal to zero
we had ended up
with these two equations this hash one
and the hash
two equations which are basically the
bi-harmonics of
the two uh potentials this was the
scalar potential and this was the vector
potential
within the context of the hemos
displacement potential
now back in uh back in our lamy's
potential
again we can say something
useful something immediately useful only
when we set this
row b vector to be equal to zero so
that's what we'll do
to consider
ruby vector to be equal to 0 therefore
what we obtain is well
you can see immediately that this is
what we obtain
we have removed this lambda plus drives
g
okay now
what is the implication of this the grad
of the laplacian of pi first of all you
note
that the laplacian of phi this phi
itself being a scalar quantity
and the laplacian operator also being
scalar this entire
entity within the bracket that is a
scalar entity
that's scalar but that is being operated
by this gradient operator and the
gradient operator
is vectorial in nature so what we are
basically going to obtain
for for instance if we specialize to
a rectangular cartesian coordinate
system okay
so this is true for any this particular
form of the equation this is true for
any
coordinate system we may choose but just
to illustrate
in a rectangular cartesian coordinate
system
we are going to end up with these three
equations
this is for the x component
this is for the y component
sorry about this symbol to correct that
and of course
the z component
now from this what we obtain
is that this entity del square phi
that is going to be just a function
of y and z because here the partial
derivative with respect to x is equal to
0
and if we substitute this particular
form the f y
z here
what we obtained is the del del y
of f of y comma z
is equal to 0 which basically implies
that this function which we thought to
be actually a function of both y
and z turns out that this is nothing
but a pure function of z that is the
that is the direct consequence
of the statement that the del del y of f
of y z y comma z is equal to zero so
what we have what we had thought from
our previous step would be a function of
uh both y and z turns out to be a pure
function of set
and subsequently if we substitute this
here then what we obtain
is that the del del z of
g z that is equal to 0 so what we were
thinking to be a function
of z turns out to be actually a constant
okay just a constant which is
independent
of x y and z
all right so ultimately what we are
really obtaining
is that del square phi this is our
conclusion
that the grad of the del square phi is
equal to zero
that means that del square phi is
nothing but
a constant now this innocently
looking equation is something very
exciting
especially if you happen to be of a
mathematically oriented mind if you
happen to have a mathematical oriented
mind this will excite you
because this is the form
which is uh which is the famous
uh poisons equation form okay so the
paul uh
so let's so this is this
this is in the form
of a poisson equation
all right and without going into much
details
of it one can think that
or one can easily understand that the
solution of this will consist
of a homogeneous part and a particular
integral
okay so uh these are the things which i
am basically concluding from
our knowledge of first-year engineering
mathematics
so if you have a differential equation a
non-homogeneous differential equation
then the solution to it will be
consisting of a homogeneous or a
complement
a homogeneous part and a particular
integral so that's exactly the same
situation here so what you will do is
first you'll set the del square phi
equal to zero that will give you the
homogeneous solution
and from the c constant you'll get a
particular integral
okay now it just so happens that
this particular situation is
is rather convenient okay it is very
convenient
in because this del square phi equal to
0 okay so from here if you consider the
del square
phi equal to 0 okay
and please note that del square phi
equal to 0 is just like a special case
of the c
okay so if c happens to be equal to 0
then
this is exactly what you will obtain and
then this is
this is really really interesting for a
mathematician because
this is the famous laplace equation and
solutions to this
have been studied in great great detail
so whenever
people arrive in any particular
framework with this kind of an equation
they are very very happy okay
because solutions to this in many many
different situations
uh are known uh this this equation
arises in different branches of physics
uh for example uh electrostatics
uh fluid mechanics and certainly as we
are now seeing
in elasticity and many other places
so so these things have been studied a
lot and uh
and the and the poison equation also the
poisson's equation that has also been
studied a lot
so so whenever we have these kinds of
second order differential forms with
this particular
form the with the laplacian of
uh sitting on the left hand side this is
this is nice
now this would have been perfectly nice
and like this would have been a perfect
situation a perfect kind of
would have been perfectly happy big if
if it had not been okay so we are not
perfectly happy
because we are working we are working
under this
restriction okay so strictly limited
to irrotational displacement fields if
somehow
somehow we we didn't have to work under
this
restriction then the lamy's potential
would have been perfect
okay because it is the lamest potential
which is giving rise to this very
convenient form
okay and it is this the solutions to
this particular thing is known
okay and that uh that would have solved
a lot of problems
unfortunately this kind of a framework
works only for this
restrictive thing that we have this
irrotational displacement phase
okay so so you see take take an account
of the overall situation as we are
developing it
we go back to the hemorrhoids
displacement potential okay again
we see that when we considered the body
forces to be zero
we ended up with this by harmonic
equation and this by harmonic equation
which is basically
harmonic equations in the three
components of the omega vector
again the bioharmonic equation has also
been studied a lot solutions to this
are known uh to a large extent
uh but
there are certain restrictions within
this formulation also
okay and the main of course main main
restriction is that
these things arise only when we set the
body force to be equal to 0
similarly here okay i must not forget to
say that
i said a little while ago that
this this formulation would have been
perfect the lamy strain for the
under the lab the laminar strain
potential would have been perfect
uh had it not been for the case of the
the restrictive
uh situation that we are working on the
irrotational flows
is the other restriction also that we
are considering this this uh
this row b to be equal to zero so had it
not been that
then this this would have been perfect
unfortunately these are there so which
means
that we have to go on to do other things
to to i mean get get more general
solutions
again we'll do that in the subsequent
lectures but
as we keep on developing our
formulations of the various displacement
potentials it is extremely important to
note
the the kind of motivations we are
working through so
every time you see somehow we are we
want to
arrive at these kinds of forms something
that is that is conveniently solved for
this by harmonic
equations these are conveniently solved
for these
uh this kind of a laplace equation or
the at least the poisson equation that
is conveniently solved for
and the ultimate uh displacement
potential that we are going to study
uh we will see that it will be up it
will be very much
motivated by by uh
by the desire to arrive at this kind of
a poison equation
okay but uh we'll try to remove the
restrictions from there
all right so with on this note uh i'll
end this lecture
and in the next one we are going to
discuss something referred to as the
gallery in potential okay which is not
the ultimate displacement potential we
are going to
going to use there will be something
else after that also referred to as the
which novel displacement potential but
that is for the future
all right thank you very much